[Music]
now normally i'm joined by a very
handsome sidekick named terry davis but
tara can be here today so instead i'm
joined by a very handsome sidekick named
jeff wright
hi jeff hi amber fun fact about jeff
he has three olympic gold medals for
fencing no i don't
fun fact about jeff he speaks icelandic
no i don't
fun fact about jeff he shouldn't
contradict me god
you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
in a memo filed this week former
president trump's impeachment attorney
said
he shouldn't be blamed for the actions
of quote
a small group of criminals a small group
of criminals is also what trump calls
his children
this year's nominees for the rock and
roll hall of fame include artists mary j
blige tina turner chaka khan and dion
warwick
said aunties oh okay
it's me i'm aunties i said that country
singer
morgan wallen's second album was ranked
number one on billboard last week
in spite of a recently released video of
him using the n-word
or dare i say because of
according to a recent report legal
experts have warned that humanoid robots
used for sex
could attack people if they are hacked
said people one year into the pandemic
that's fine according to a new
investigation
four leading companies knowingly sold
baby food that contained
high levels of heavy metals officials
became suspicious when marcus weighed in
at 2.5 tons
i love him he's so cute don't you pick
him up you throw your back out
marcus and an auction house in boston
recently began
accepting bids for a harvard sweater
that belonged to president john f
kennedy
proving that even death isn't enough to
stop someone from bringing up the fact
that they went to harvard
today was international winter bike to
work day
or as i call it
and finally according to a recent report
3 500 black people in los angeles have
received the coronavirus vaccine
and i hope the other half of the wayans
family gets it real soon
and that was the monologue jeff did you
like the monologue
yeah i did i'm happy to hear that i
would have been happier to hear it in
icelandic
[Music]
now friends it's black history month and
you know what that means
america is lying about how much we loved
malcolm x
martin luther king jr and rosa parks but
black people i'm here to tell you that
you don't have to be the leader of a
movement a pop star or
a president to be worthy of
acknowledgement this month or
ever so today i'm gonna celebrate the
black people who
are important to my history these are my
parents who raised me
i call them mommy daddy mom introduced
me to soap operas or as she likes to
call them
her stories she taught me that it is
perfectly fine to have an
hour in the day that is just for you to
watch beautiful white people cheat on
their spouse
die mysteriously and then come back to
life as their evil twin only to cheat
again
and my perfect dad saved his four
daughters from countless spiders our
whole entire lives
we honor you this february mommy daddy
thanks for being a part of my history
next up is cousin jazz now when i was 11
and she was 14
i asked her what all the rappers meant
when they said let's 69. so
she took an upright fork and a spoon and
then flipped over the fork and made them
kiss
thank you cousin jazz for making me
laugh and laugh
and for making me the most knowledgeable
kid on the playground in seventh grade
this february we salute all our favorite
cool cousins
next up mrs lemon she was the first
black teacher i ever had
and she was so smart and pretty and
spoke spanish and i knew
not only did she care about me that she
really saw me
i had never felt seen at school before
thank you to all the black teachers
going out of your way to help black
students feel seen
mrs lemon i may not remember como hablar
en espanol
pero nunca voyage
and lastly a big part of my history is
mark
the old doorman at old town ale house
across the street from second city in
chicago
back when i performed there we would
always have a drink at old town
afterwards and
mark would always card everyone but me
and instead he would grab me by the
upper arm and go
you what you are doing at that theater
is important
we need representation and you're it you
make your community proud so be proud
and it always scared me a little bit but
it was also encouragement i was getting
nowhere else
and i thought how nice of him to lift me
up like this i love him he was the best
so this february remember that this
celebration isn't just for the people
who have come and gone
but also the people who are here right
now your bus drivers your clerks at the
grocery store your dentists your
favorite cousins that get in trouble for
being too grown
you matter and i see you and mom and dad
are going to be so mad at me for being
like
mommy watches stories and daddy kills
spiders instead of like talking about
the great things they accomplished but
hey
that's the doofus you raised that's on
you happy black history month everybody
now in addition to learning about
important black americans another big
part of black history month is
white people asking how can i be a
better ally
great question let us show you now in a
segment called
ally of the week
[Music]
of the week recently a school in
michigan had a meeting with parents to
address
problems they've been having with racism
in their school district and
in the middle of that meeting while a
father was talking about his son
this happened i remember when i
went to his bedroom to say good night
and he was crying
of the abuse that he was enduring in
this school system
then why did you stay in mexico
yes she did you need to leave play it
again
that's right lady we don't completely
get to see you
are the ally of the week take that you
got my order wrong energy and punish
this
dizzy [ __ ] with his hands up like i
didn't know we weren't doing racist [ __ ]
today
how does it feel to be hilariously
kindly
and completely destroyed by someone who
i'm assuming is the size of a p
you don't have to be a superhero to be
an ally you can just be a person who's
had enough
and also a soprano the anger that rose
up in that lady's chest was she told
you're raggedy behind what was
what really is a shining example of what
an ally can be
i have watched that video 20 times and
tonight after the show
i'm gonna go home and watch it 20 more
in fact i'm gonna watch it again right
now
you almost never get to see a racist out
in the cold light of day loud and wrong
get ripped to stress by an entire
community
it was beautiful and it would not have
been possible without
the ally of the week so wherever you are
whoever you are we salute you
now let's get back to the news on friday
burgess owens a pro-trump republican
congressman from utah
addressed the house of representatives
he made a speech defending a motion to
recite the pledge of allegiance during
all house judiciary committee meetings
he did this after recently voting to
overturn the presidential election
you guys his speech was very sad he
talked about things like
athletes needing to stand for the flag
and like how black people used to be
patriots but we lost that
and then when he was done talking
congressman hakeem jeffries
destroyed him worse than a mortal combat
fatality
yes indeed it was beautiful it was
almost like going to church
say that and the best thing is his whole
sermon was caught on video
and that video made the church say amen
amen
it made the church say hallelujah
hallelujah
this man hakeem jeffries said this
i was hoping to engage with the new
distinguished
gentleman from utah as he sat here
lecturing us
about patriotism amen and i was just
going to ask him
how he voted after a violent mob
attacked the capitol to hunt down
members of congress amen to hang mike
pence
to assassinate nancy pelosi
and you want to sit here and lecture us
about patriotism
lecturing us on your first day do you
really want to do that
it's not about words it's about actions
you know what
explain your actions on january 7th
when you supported an insurrection and i
was ready to have a dialogue
were you you no no
no no
he won't do it's my time and you don't
really want any of this either
yes he shall not be moved
you're reclaiming my time the capital
was desecrated desecrated the
confederate flag was bandied about
discriminated that didn't even happen in
this capital
during the civil war obliterated
that's an insurrection it's an infection
that's addition it's their tradition
that's find undemocratic dramatic
that's problematic oh here i'm going to
and the american thing to do is to stand
up to it
[Music]
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips and a lot of digital exclusives
and a lot of this
you